you're watching screen junkie Central
today's episode is brought to you by
T-Mobile the uncarrier
this is screen junkies movie fights
yes welcome to San Diego live from
screen jockey Central live long and
prosper this is gonna be so amazing
place I'm here with the lovely at least
Star Trek Edition this is amazing I Know
Dan Murrell is backstage and he is
freaking out right now yes we have some
great guests and of course you can watch
this live on Facebook on YouTube on SJ
plus and for all our programming go to
screenjackies.com Central we're here
live in San Diego and I'm honored to do
this I'm so happy we're gonna get right
to it we have we're going to ask some of
the toughest questions Star Trek
questions there are with some of the
best experts we could get I'm so happy
they made the time to be here we also
have some surprises in store that you're
going to see uh so this is a fun show so
get excited yeah what do you say shall
we get to it who loves Star Trek
yes
yes have you guys seen Star Trek Beyond
yet
it's pretty fun we got to see the
premiere is pretty fun 50 years of Star
Trek what an honor let's do this first
up you know him he's the champion of
this show movie fights screen junkie's
biggest Star Trek fan Mr Dan Murrell
[Applause]
s
out right that's not blasphemy
uh next up I'm honored to have this guy
he's a friend of uh he came in to help
us a friend of Scott Mance I'm so happy
he's the writer and producer of the cult
classic free enterprise and the author
of the 50-year mission ladies and
gentlemen Mark Altman
oh
welcome back
uh great and finally this guy has
written for Star Trek Voyager Enterprise
the Next Generation in a movie called
First Contact as well as Generations
guys it's Brandon Braga
I think Dan these guys have literally
written a book on Star Trek you're in
trouble I'm in big trouble guys thank
you so much for coming oven
yeah great time to be here uh I I'm told
you've seen the shows I'm excited this
is a debate show so have fun with this
very scholarly right I understand it's
very professorial yes uh and what's
different about this show uh unlike most
shows is uh we didn't we didn't get to
prepare this you guys are legit trekkies
so what we have is these are blind Star
Trek fights because some of these fights
are tough people have their favorites
but we're going to be asking best
Captain best movie and all these things
and you're gonna have to it's based on
your order which will be random which if
we don't have our numbers we should make
those now because I'm going to pull can
you rip those for me yes um you're gonna
be based on the order of we draw a
number and then you'll get to go first
so you have a slight Advantage
potentially depending on how you see it
but the audience won't know if you if if
it's your favorite you're arguing but
you got to commit to whatever you end up
choosing any questions
no no oh I love this Dan how crazy is
this
it's arguing Star Trek things with with
a guy who literally wrote the book on
Star Trek and the guy who wrote some of
my favorite episodes of Star Trek of all
time so and movies it's yeah I'm nervous
I'm nervous you're nervous
a quick rule reminder scoring is based
on facts passion and creativity and I
may be using the audience you guys have
some voting panels I believe too I may
be coming to you to help me do this and
I think they're watching live right yeah
people are watching live and I'm gonna
be watching out for the tweets so if
you're watching at home or even if
you're in the audience you can tweet and
use the hashtag movie fights live and
I'll try and read out as much as I can
and I'm looking for some great tweets
and some help on choosing the winner and
we also want to thank our great sponsor
too I want to thank T-Mobile one of our
presenting sponsors here with double the
LTE coverage you can follow the fights
in more places so thank you for the help
that's bringing a screen took
essentially so thank you so much
T-Mobile uh all right shall we do this
no cheat those Bail Bonds no cheating
all right very scientific very
scientific this will determine the order
of this first fight and the first fight
sorry do we have a video before we do
well yeah Andy we we can ask if you want
we can ask the question and then while
that video is playing we can figure it
out because we got some special guests
to weigh in on this question we got some
very special guests to answer the the
first question that we'll be fighting
today best Star Trek movie
let's hear from some Shrek people
themselves and see what they thought
who we got
all right all right Chris Pine Zachary
Quinto from Star Trek Beyond we have a
show every week called movie fights it's
where real fans every week get into
movie debates nice but important [__] in
the world so important it's super fun
but I want to know your opinion on all
these Star Trek questions okay it's all
in good fun great the first one about
that other than the movies that you're
in what do you think the best Star Trek
movie is I'm probably gonna go for the
obvious one and say Roth of cons you
know we're at the con Wrath of Khan
Wrath of Khan The Wrath of Khan Star
Trek the motion picture okay do you have
Kirk coming back he's Rusty he's out of
the chair he has this incredible
conflict with Deckard bones calls them
on there and then you also got Spock
coming back and joining the mission but
after failing to achieve Colima he has
an agenda a Personal Agenda which is
against the mission which is to you know
engage with this mysterious life form
the the bald girl oh yeah I Leah and her
relationship with Deckard what I love
about it is that the uh the the villain
of the piece uh is this the sort of uh
you know sort of
vastra uh sort of omnipresent being
which is destroying and cannibalizing
worlds and spaceships as it goes
actually turns out to be a man-made
object Voyager uh and so it's very
rodentary it's very Roddenberry okay
man I love that Carl Urban could talk
for 90 seconds straight about Star Trek
the motion picture that's that's a guy
that knows his stuff he does culinar he
broke out that's amazing all right well
Mark you picked first so you're number
one let's tell what's the best Star Trek
movie well you know I was gonna go with
Carl for a second and pick Star Trek the
motion picture but then I realized I'm
really competitive and I want to win so
I decided I'll go with Star Trek 2 the
Wrath of Khan
all right give me just a little Spiel
why why is that the best well look you
know anyone who's a big Fantasy Island
fan can tell you wait no that's probably
not the best argument for Ricardo but um
you know Star Trek 2 is like the
greatest episode of The Original Series
in a sense you know even though it
doesn't have necessarily the scope of
Star Trek the motion picture what it has
is Great Character moments it's the
first time that you deal with the
characters are actually aging Kirk is
dealing with his own mortality he's
dealing with the fact it has an
illegitimate son that kind of happens
when you screw around with every woman
in the universe so I think to his you
know credit you know Nick Meyer said you
know we're going to deal with the
repercussions of unprotected sex in the
23rd Century
um that's a great a great thing you know
great cautionary tale
um but I think that you know ultimately
you know certainly the battle in the
Matera nebula is one of the Great Space
Battles of all time it's not just a
bunch of things it's not a bunch of
insects attacking the Enterprise and
destroying it in 30 seconds and Captain
Kirk being stranded on a planet for
three hours no it's actually you know
Kirk uh you know in a cat and mouse game
with the um with the Reliant which is
fantastic and it's a great cast Ricardo
model bombs great but so is Paul
Winfield uh as uh Captain uh Captain
Terrell so I just think that you know
and of course who can deny the power of
the denuma spoiler alert when Spock dies
at the end of the movie uh I mean anyone
who saw that movie in 1982 uh you know
had an attachment to these characters
you know was in tears because you didn't
know Spock was going to be back three
years later in Star Trek three you know
you thought this was it for for Leonard
um so it is moving it is powerful it is
exciting
um it's a roller coaster ride and it's
heartfelt and it's by far the best Star
Trek motion picture all right good
opening Sparks Dan first Contact I'm
sorry yeah I got the second pick and I
chose and I love the original series I
that's what got me into Star Trek but
the one that was on that I grew up with
and was the Next Generation so I'm a t
engineer at heart and the movie that I
loved when it came out and I still go
back to is uh Star Trek first Contact
um I love first time stock up
this is very intimidating to talk about
with Brandon here but I will attempt to
talk and not seem like a suck up but no
uh first Contact I love because it it
really paid off I I love what they did
with Generations in Bridging the Gap but
what I love with first Contact was that
it really was that bridge between the
series and the movies and that you had
this underlying theme with Picard and
the Borg and the Damage that the Borg
did to him and I love the fact that you
had the Borg which are an awesome
Villain Like tng's signature villain I
love that you had the Borg in a movie
it's got great action which you don't
see in all the Star Trek movies you see
and some of them the newer ones are a
little more action-packed I think than
the older ones but you have great action
but you also have the story of humanity
the time travel aspect which is a great
Hallmark in any great Star Trek film is
time travel you get to see that moment
of first Contact and I love the reveal
that first Contact was with the Vulcans
and that that that is such a seminal
moment in Star Trek history and you get
to see that you get to see the whole
hero worship with zefram Cochrane and
and that he is a flawed person and and I
just love what it has to say about
Picard paying off the relationship with
the Borg it's got great action has a lot
to say about humanity and about what a
Star Trek what you know what that
actually means and uh it's I I love that
movie I don't know about the audience
but I think you've convinced Brandon I
think he is now convinced all right
Brandon who wrote first Contact I wrote
the first Contact and I'm telling you
you're wrong
what's your what's your pick
well you made it I mean you make it
sound like an amazing movie
I perhaps it's because it's the first
Star Trek movie
actually this the first one I saw was
Khan but the
the first Star Trek movie that really
got me excited about Star Trek
personally was the Voyage Home
and
[Applause]
um I remember where I saw it at what
theater I saw it I remember the crowd's
reaction to every moment
and I haven't seen a Star Trek movie
that had that audience reaction and I
think
it was the humor I don't think those
characters had ever been more human
than in that movie and more relatable
these actors even though they were by
the way
first move or breath the con we're so
old they weren't that old they were like
when it wasn't their 40s that's not that
old
facing mortality at 44.
don't I don't buy it and mataro nebula
the ships don't even do anything
he's like Khan's quoting Shakespeare
then you cut over to Kirk and by the way
looked good
uh and I think that Voyage Home had
one of the best
Concepts driving any Star Trek Story the
idea that an alien craft some a kind of
terrifying monolithic craft comes and
starts to destroy the Earth for reasons
we have we cannot understand until we
well we could have Dawn Steele who is
the executive at Paramount at the time
wanted to subtitle the probe because she
thought no one could understand what it
was doing so she was telling harp
Bennett and Leonard Nimoy that they had
a subtitle the program
like and of course they fought then
thank God they never subtitled it you're
making my argument uh
but uh okay I got two words for you John
Chuck as a Klingon I mean as bad as
Christopher Lloyd was as Scrooge in Star
Trek 3 John shuck come on Holmes and
yo-yo they're two young fans I didn't
know that show that I liked them as the
Klingon uh but I mean no peace
that the these aliens have come
to contact a different form of life that
lives in the sea that had gone extinct
was
is still a powerful idea it's so simple
it's so clean the movie is fun from
beginning to end
granted there's that terrible scene with
Catherine Hicks slapping that guy
that was not a good scene you remember
that that was very stilted but uh
to this day I I may have picked third
but this is my first choice
all right rebuttals go ahead yeah yeah
no I think I love all these are all
great movies these are all great Star
Trek movies maybe the three best Star
Trek movies I think personally I think
that not Star Trek five come on not Star
Trek five what is a foot spot what does
that come on Starship
um I think that uh I think wrathicon has
the great personal story going on
between Kirk and Khan which is awesome
and I think that Star Trek 4 has the
humor and the great interpersonal like
Star Trek force my favorite character
movie of all the stars especially with
the original crew and that you get such
great interaction between all the
characters I think that first Contact
has all of those aspects and combined in
one movie Plus Great action which might
I think the only knock on Wrath of Khan
is that the space battle is is not that
Dynamic and I think it's because you
know it was 82 and you have the kind of
special effects that you do now I think
with the battle with the Borg you have
that personal connection you have you
know Captain Picard that that great
speech you know the language feature on
here it's that's so awesome and I just
love that you're paying off that
relationship in a movie but I also think
that you do have the Dynamics between
the characters also and you have data
being tempted by humanity and you're
paying off so many of these story lines
from these characters over seven years
of television and one previous movie and
to get that all in one movie and to have
it be satisfying and it's a crowd
pleaser it's it's it's as satisfying on
an action level as any Blockbuster movie
would be and to do that in a Trek movie
I think is really difficult and to have
all those elements present I think
that's very difficult to do Mark
thoughts well I'll tell you first
contact's not the best Star Trek movie
for for one reason Picard is not John
McLean okay Patrick thinks he's John
McLean but Picard is not John McLean and
didn't belong on and the way they
originally wrote the script was Riker
was on the Enterprise and Picard was on
the planet with that from Cochrane which
is the way it should have been but
Patrick wanted to fight and bleep and so
of course he became the badass yes which
is not true to what the show was now
first contact's a great movie and it's a
textbook for people who are making Star
Trek movies now that they could learn a
lot from
um but as far as Star Trek 4 is
concerned I would negate Brandon's
argument by saying time travel is not
about paper mache heads anyone who's
seen Star Trek 4 all of a sudden Leonard
Nimoy thinks he's tarkovsky and it
becomes a surreal weird thing with paper
mache heads and the Enterprise is
suddenly thrust back in time okay that
cannot be the greatest Star Trek movie
of all time plus it has that Dreadful
Leonard rosenmann score which is the
worst score to a Star Trek movie of any
of the films and that's worse than
Dennis Dennis McCarthy's score for
Generations so it's pretty bad but um oh
I know right but uh so I I think that as
great as Voyage Home is with its
ecological green message before it was
in Vogue and it's the only film that
doesn't have a black hat villain uh or a
con character ripping off Khan which you
know is typical of almost every Star
Trek movie it's a great movie but it's
not as good as Khan the the track
tragedy of this character who was
stranded and left on seti Alpha 5 and
seeks revenge it's a Shakespearean drama
so when Brandon says he's quoting
Shakespeare of course he's quoting
Shakespeare this is textbook Meyer
should have given Shakespeare a
co-writing credit
Star Trek six yeah even more so
Brandon other thoughts before we go we
make a vote here
I mean I cannot I just you know this is
about a personal favorite
I I really enjoyed Khan when I saw it
but as someone who was not an a regular
viewer of the series
I just I I thought it was cool but I
didn't really understand what was going
on between Picard and Kirk uh it just
Voyage Home to me is more accessible I
agree that first contact with the kind
of like the Vulcan Nativity three wise
men nativity scene was a good way to
bring in new people
um I think one of the reasons these JJ
Abrams pictures are so appealing is
because they are just a little bit
broader you know and I having written a
couple of the movies one good one not
good uh I think the TV show is one thing
but the movies should have a broader
appeal that's my opinion that's what
this is about and I think Voyage Home
has that
wow all right
it's this is tough yeah this is tough
that's three smart people who know this
material and it's also really hard to
fact check because they all know their
facts oh yeah they know their facts
anything happening there before I go I'm
gonna go to you guys to help me here yes
a lot of people on Twitter Zen out says
movie fights live Star Trek is a dream
come true and I also love from variety
films they're so awesome to see moral
Dan nervous the king of movie fights
live showing his human side
yes
all right I also did a poll but I went
we did a poll I'm trying to do it
because I'm trying to I want the I want
you guys to help me here because this is
too tough I know I'm the judge I'm
supposed to but I have a whole audience
that's listening I'm trying to figure
out how to have he goes before three can
I have the lights on the on you have
your cards right
about front can I see some lights on the
crowd so I can help them uh so uh there
we go what I'm gonna do I'm gonna try
this if it doesn't work I have another
method if you'd like to vote for Dan
raise your one raise one hand flat out
raise your hand up one hand if you want
Dan if you wanted to have four people
vote the black side of your panel lights
please house lights and if you want to
vote for Brandon the white side of your
panel okay see the lights hands up for
Dan Black for Mark and uh White for
brand I need the light stick keep them
up uh do they stay up I think it's the
white it looks white to me looks like
the white has it wow yeah right on thank
you yes so you agree disappointing that
is so wrong hands are very difficult
it's like you know hands are very
difficult to see with cards
but there were like seven hands
a comedy episode of Star Trek could
never be the best episode that's why
Trouble with Tribbles can never be the
best Star Trek episode that is why that
is why Fistful of datas can't be the
best Next Generation episode and Star
Trek four can't be the best movie
because Star Trek is ultimately
accessibility
they're already still fighting this is a
great show for the record the Twitter
poll
my prediction for the fight nope Mark
you won the Twitter poll yes thank you
Twitter obviously
those social those those tweets are a
lot more knowledgeable about starting
all right we have a round two and I
think we have another video from some
special guests to help set this up we do
the fight this one will be doing is
what's the best Star Trek alien species
ever
let's see what the cast of Star Trek
Beyond thought the coolest the coolest
Star Trek alien species ever
that is it
all time what do you think is the
coolest alien species that we've seen on
Star Trek Jayla whatever she is
um
they even say what she is no no I kind
of like the andorians I like that funny
little uh antenna the blue faces they're
they're white haircuts
the Borg oh the Borg you know until the
Borg came on Next Generation you know
the series was okay but they defined it
that was the threat that I remember as a
kid watching that show freaked me out
and I like the Borg as well because they
almost select the other side of the
Federation coin you know they were
they're also moving through the Galaxy
assimilating worlds but in a far darker
less productive way I might have to uh
you know been the andorians and agree
with Carl on that one I keep thinking of
corporate my maneuver and I haven't seen
that episode since I was like probably
16 yeah but that alien I remember seeing
as a kid like they're just playing mind
games yeah like I remember when I was
eight I didn't understand except the
fact that there are huge heads you know
um but then later on I'm like oh he's
screwing you know so my level engagement
kept kind of evolving but that's always
kind of stayed with me so I don't know
what they're called but I would scary
ones for me because yeah he's always in
the end credits yeah exactly
[Laughter]
awesome some scary looking alien said
but I just love watching Dan's face when
you're talking to the Stars the Star
Trek Beyond about this stuff yeah I've
been terrified this entire week the cast
of Star Trek Beyond and then I have to
fight these guys hey Mark did you see
Star Trek Beyond
what'd you think I haven't seen it yet
does it you know
other people's room haven't seen it yet
so I think I'm not going to talk about
it good point there you go yeah no
spoilers all right so uh we just pulled
numbers we know who's going first
Brandon you got first prick that's fair
uh best Star Trek alien species ever
you should whoever wins the round should
have the first pick of the next round
well you won apparently do you want to
do it that way uh Mike no we won't know
who goes second
uh Vulcans uh Vulcans and uh it's to me
the the it's a no-brainer
Spock and the concept of the Vulcans
would lay the the DNA of every Star Trek
type character to come after it which is
a character struggling with an internal
dichotomy a character battling in his
case with his emotions and his logic
if you think about the characters that
follow
Wharf half Klingon half human seven of
nine half Borg half human this was the
primordial character that Gene
Roddenberry created it would inform Star
Trek for 50 years
it was an enduring species they survived
every
um every series had a Vulcan in it
not the Deep Space Nine did not correct
not a regular but the others had regular
Vulcan characters
um
and I just think that if you look at the
dramatic mileage that the characters
have had I mean if
I know Kirk is the captain but I think
if one if you had to pick one character
to put on a poster of Star Trek it would
be Spock
um
all right Dan you pick next best alien
species so many and I had a few that
were going through my head and I went
with just I had to agree with Urban and
Carl Urban and Simon Peck at the Borg
are just I
I had the board came at the time of Star
Trek when you know the Vulcans and the
romulans and the Klingons are great
their their Trek like you know
Hallmarks they've been and every series
are always the bad guys there's so many
Romulan ships out they run into so many
for somebody that's supposed to be in
the neutral zone there's so many Romulan
ships just hanging out in space and and
I feel like that Trek was also kind of
the next generation was looking for its
next big you know their signature alien
and the Borg are so unlike any other
species because you know all the
different species on Star Trek kind of
have their own different characteristics
but what it usually comes down to is
diplomacy or they're gonna talk to this
guy or talk to this Vulcan or this
romulan's got a heart or this Klingon
you know like War if it's got honor the
Borg are so cool because they are just
so unique there's no negotiation with
them there's no tactics to be taken with
them they're Unstoppable you can't fight
them you you try to speak with them and
all they say is you will be assimilated
and in a weird way
what I like the most about the Borg and
why I think they're kind of cool is if
you twist your brain around a little bit
it kind of makes sense because they're
about efficiency and and they're not
necessarily Sinister they're just like
no listen we're just trying to make
things the most efficient they could
possibly be and that just means you're
going to assimilate you and everybody's
part of one Collective and you know it's
much more efficient that way even though
they do Terrible Things the service of
that I love that you can kind of twist
your head around and go like well you
know
it's not that bad but they also look
cool uh I I love that they that it
requires I love when that when the
Enterprise my favorite time of the
Enterprise I really do something is when
they face a photo that they don't know
how to beat and it requires some
creative thinking and the Borg are
always that enemy it's always an enemy
that like no conventional way will ever
work to beat them we have to think
outside the box and I love when they
bring that kind of into creative
thinking into Star Trek all right Mark
you're number three what's uh your pick
well you know hearing the Vulcans and
the Borg you know made me think I I
there's so many great Star Trek aliens
you know the fact that nobody picked the
Klingons was astonishing
um but then I was at a convention once
and some Klingon wouldn't let me in the
room with his batlet and I was like I've
sort of over the Klingons after that
it's taking his part way too seriously
you know the romulans ever since the
original series sort of let me down
never been great you know either a
couple of great episodes the Next
Generation like The Defector with the
romulans but they never lived up to
their billing I mean Nero and the new
movies yeah not so great you know then I
look at like the binars they were pretty
cool
um the Baku not so great the Gorn were
awesome the big lizard guy you know take
you know and but and the herogen you
know they were they were cool so a
species eight five seven two or whatever
they were called eight four fact check
yeah yeah but so I really had to think
about it and this is what I came up with
you remember the Silicon Rock Creature
From The Savage curtain like he was and
if you touched him you burnt you you
were burned okay now to me he's the
greatest alien of all time because this
rock guy turned his whole methane Planet
into a Class M planet right and then he
creates Abraham Lincoln
and
and surac and gets them to fight the
greatest evil in Humanity's history so
he had Colonel green Attila the Hun
Donald Trump it was amazing and and and
they fought to the death and like you
know you think the Savage curtain that's
a pretty silly stupid episode but that's
a really cool alien and it was also like
when the original Star Trek was really
audacious it wasn't just like a guy in a
bumpy forehead it was like this rock
creature with like nine eyes and if you
touched it it like seared your skin so I
I want to think outside the box you know
I could have gone with the Klingons and
I probably would have won but I want to
be daring I want to live on the edge and
I decided to go with the Silicon Rock
creature from uh The Savage curtain what
do you guys think of his on the edge
pick I'm one of those that thinks that
that was one of the silly that was one
where I think that they didn't have any
money and they're like what costumes do
we have they're like uh I have Lincoln
and a couple of vulconeers and uh
Genghis Khan outfit and they're like get
them in front of the cameras in five
minutes we have to go you misunderstood
because I really meant the milk ocean
it's from Specter of the gun
uh yeah no I mean it's certainly I
that's the goofy side of track which I
get it's got the camp value but you know
if we're talking coolest Dan you're just
young I you just don't appreciate the
genius
the question was [__] was species
which I think in insinuates more than
just a one alien uh appearance there are
a whole bunch of Styrofoam rocks on that
planet so I'm sure there were a lot of
these rock creatures we just couldn't
see this was the he because it was it
started as a rock and it turned into the
guy so and then he made you know he
wanted has good versus evil it gets to
the very heart of the the moral uh drama
of Star Trek where we literally are
seeing good which is stronger good
versus evil and evil runs from good okay
fundamental message a tenant of Star
Trek I'm having a real tough time
selling so
look the Borg I love the Borg
I wrote
a lot of episodes with Borg in
um Voyager
and I wrote first Contact and I'm the
reason I disagree with you
is that
um they're villains
but they're a deeply flawed concept
they're cool the idea of the collective
and and how threatening that might be to
a free Society in a free thinking
Society
they're zombies
they're really boring when you think
about it and the first challenge we had
in first Contact before we invented the
board Queen was that we couldn't do two
hours of a movie with these guys chasing
people around
Star Trek species need a voice
and I again I go back to to the Vulcans
of having the original kind of Star Trek
voice the collective
the queen came later
and I just don't think they're as
nuanced a species they're more
frightening by the way they were there
were there were Vulcan villains too
throughout the years so they they could
be both but I just don't think there is
nuance and then yeah
you need to get back in the box
uh guy who wrote the Borg uh
this is fun okay uh no it's here's what
I think they're cool is that the Vulcans
I like the Vulcans they're they're
logical uh they're logical they have no
emotion they're also logical and they
have no emotion uh I love the Vulcans
but the Vulcans are always it seems like
used as a bouncing board for other
characters to bounce off of and or they
lose control and they're not Vulcans
anymore
um when we're talking about best species
I think it's not only the species
themselves and I'll agree that that you
know if it was just bork if all you're
talking about was just looking and
listening to Borg then you will be
assimilated you know I would agree that
that was all that there was but I think
what makes them the best species is not
just themselves but what the change that
they brought because as Star Trek it
gotten to a point where everything was
kind of expected and they knew how to
beat everybody they knew the relations
for everybody and what the Borg brought
in was this foe that they were able to
stretch out across different series and
seasons of just like every time you'd
beat them they get better and they come
back at you and you'd beat them and you
say okay we're done with the Borg and
they come back at you and they get even
better and they get even better if you
beat them in their time they're going to
time travel back and try to get you back
in the past and that's what I like
that's what I think makes them so cool
and so unique and Star Trek is that
they can't be beaten by conventional
means and they evolve and that's that's
their only purpose is to evolve and I
think that's so cool do you know the
board were originally supposed to be an
insect race but they they couldn't
afford to do it and the Borg sort of
came out of in you know late 80s the
cyberpunk movement and Maurice Hurley
created it for Q who which is still one
of the best Borg episodes it doesn't get
much love because you know obviously
Best of Both Worlds is sort of the one
that everybody talks about
um but I I I agree with Brandon I think
the Borg are a great villain I think
they've been used phenomenally well but
you know then you have episodes like
iborg you know where it's like oh I'm
not happy being a borg and it gets so
you know touchy-feely don't talk about
you like you know I think it just I I
you know I think I think the Borg
haven't had the impact and as Brandon
said as the Vulcans have through all the
shows I mean if you look at what they
did in Enterprise one of the most I
think cleverest things they did with
that show was to sort of make the
Vulcans the villain that they were
holding Humanity back and that was
really interesting because that was not
something that we would have expected
knowing spocking knowing the original
series but that said that silicon Rock
creature I was a Savage curtains
I think it's two on one yeah Brandon
last thoughts
I can't get behind it uh
I I I can't get behind the rock creature
I mean I
I
know I'm right about this
all right so sad I think every all right
I think we got it let that that was that
was fun I I think it did really come
down to Dan and uh Brown what did
Twitter say yeah so we did run a poll on
Twitter 51 went to Vulcans then 35 Borg
and sorry 14 to Silicon rock monster I
take back everything I said about the
Twitter yeah give it you go but let's
see what the audience thought all right
can we see the lights again sorry Mark
I'm not even gonna have the hands-free
this time
wait for Dan Black for Brennan
I need the lights why wow that's pretty
even
oh I see a lot of black so let's give it
to the Silicon Rock creature
Alicia what do you think
I got a gut I don't want to say it out
loud you tell me yours and if it matches
mine they win I think it's the black
that's what I see too
wait who was that black has it oh we got
it again it's the Vulcans wow Brian's
good at this game that makes you a two
oh oh guys thanks for those who agreed
thank you I am never going on The Price
is Right
during that I was Googling things I
never thought I ever would like the Borg
insect what is silicon rock monster what
is silica yeah I love that I'm just like
no listen the Borg are interesting the
guy who had to write and make them
interesting for years and years you're
wrong about the board Creator sir so far
the audience picked everyone I would
pick let's go to round three guys here
we go this is a doozy best Star Trek
Captain
and we have some fans who are going to
talk about it right now
best Star Trek Captain of all time
Picard you know when I went off to
college I remember Next Generation came
on I was always kind of Blown Away going
wow the quality but there's something
about me that's part of the original you
know I had to be Captain Kirk Captain
Kirk yeah
best Captain yes oh I you know what now
I got a lot of love for uh John Luke
Picard yeah because I like the way he
speaks like this it's an amazing thing
that he could do make it so engaged it's
all about speaking in a very very sort
of pronounced way Jose but I gotta go
with Kirk just because he was the he's
the uh first and as much as I love love
love uh Jean-Luc Picard um I'm just a
bit of a you know old-fashioned boy sir
I you're busy with Simon why are you
talking like that
Shatner's Kirk fo shizzo Captain Kirk
Shannon's OG Kirk is just special beyond
all measure
when he wrestles he's just wrestling
that kid strangely and he has the pants
up to his waist and he's doing his then
you have this didn't you win them at
auction yeah
all right and I have to say lovely dust
on Twitter says Simon and Carl give me
life it is so refreshing seeing actual
passion and nerdiness for Star Trek in
Hollywood I agree it's so fun to see
that it is all right guys this is the
Battle of all battles uh uh Brandon got
the first pick you so you get your first
choice who's the best Star Trek and I'm
curious who's gonna say best Star Trek
Captain
well this is a tough one for me because
I I know some of these actors who played
the captains so I'm hesitate to come out
publicly and uh
but but I've written I I mean I don't
keep I'm sorry to keep playing the
writing card but uh I I wrote for Picard
I wrote for Kirk I wrote for Janeway
um and I wrote for uh Captain Archer
I gotta go Picard and the reason is
okay now I know I'm gonna lose this
that was amazing I can't tell if you
were are you happy or sad I can't okay
I'm in a shot yes all right
okay well look
it may be that it's because it's the
first Captain I wrote for so there may
be a Sentimental aspect
to this but
I think the obvious pick is Kirk but
when I think about Star Trek uh here at
its 50th Anniversary I think of Kirk is
kind of the Proto Captain he was the
first
he was
but really it wasn't until Jean
Roddenberry
created Picard that he evolved what a
Star Trek Captain could be and to the
modern captain that I think has really
endured
I think Picard
um was a more fully realized character
in some ways than Kirk was I don't think
there's been and with all due respect to
everybody involved with the creation of
the character the other captains no
Captain ever has come close to Picard
since then
and uh I who would I serve under I I'm
going to serve under Picard I just think
he's got his am I allowed to cuss on
this show
uh he's got his [__] together like he's
he's a he's a better leader to me I feel
safer with him I liked his Enterprise
better I just it was it just felt like a
more welcoming comfortable place so I'm
going Picard so you like the Holiday Inn
as well
I forget the Four Seasons I wasn't
talking I wasn't talking about the
Furnishings I was talking about the the
captain gotcha all right Dan you picked
second who are you picking James
Tiberius Kirk
[Applause]
and here's why I'll tell you why because
it's best captain and and I and like I
said I'm a TNG at heart and I love
Captain Picard but here's the thing
about Captain Kirk was uh uh one of the
appeals of the next generation was that
by that time uh you know uh 70 80 years
down the line uh Starfleet was a little
more evolved uh and and the ships were a
little more evolved and it was a less of
a um you weren't at war with the
Klingons anymore it was more peaceful
time it was more about exploration and
that's great
um Captain Picard it was kind of like
managing a cruise ship a lot of the
times
um here's what I like about Captain Kirk
it's space the final frontier and when
you're talking about the original series
Captain Kirk's Enterprise that was down
and dirty exploration every week you're
getting caught in the Foley and Webb
you're introduced to the Klingons you're
introduced to the romulans for the first
use the Silicon rockers the Silicon rock
creatures and hortas that go through
walls and stuff and I love the fact that
the Enterprise was at an earlier time
and Captain Kirk didn't have the benefit
of all the experience diplomatically
with romulans and Klingons that Captain
Picard had he was encountering these
things for the first time and he was
literally flying by the seat of his
pants he didn't have a ship that had
holodecks and like lounges and huge like
10-story arboretums and 10 forward like
that Enterprise was falling apart yeah
it was about to explode half the time
and he kept that thing going that
Enterprise should have been done in like
six months and he I I like to think that
they completed that five-year Mission
before the movies he kept that thing out
investigating the unknown exploring deep
space the first guy to see all these
things he kept the crew today together
and he kept that ship together I respect
Picard he was in a time of Peace he was
a manager Kirk was a leader
wow all right I just I just want to fact
check because Captain Kirk did have the
Holodeck in the Animated Series okay
yes the Holodeck was invented in the
practical joker episode of the animated
series and the fact that I know that is
probably the most pathetic thing that I
could offensively I bet it broke down
right 2 000 page books about Star Trek
that are on sale now so
um did the Holodeck break down in that
episode it did not yes it did yes
all right well you're picking
[Laughter]
uh what are you picking Mark best
Captain well you know I I need
clarification on Kirk are we talking
about fat Elvis or young Elvis are we
talking about the original series of the
movie or a movie I'm talking about TOS
cos one through three damn I thought I
could get that through uh wrestling uh
shirtless uh on the alien planet green
girl yeah well you know this is really
difficult for me because after all I did
make a movie
free Enterprise's only purpose was to
extol The Genius of Captain James T Kirk
and William Shatner so for me to take
any other Star Trek Captain
it's not logical but I'll try I was
thinking okay I was thinking about
Captain Merrick from bread and circuses
you know who turned his the Roman Planet
into gladorial games but he was a bit of
a a loser
um of course it was Captain will Decker
uh you know but he was like a lunatic
um and uh you know rammed his
shuttlecraft into the Doomsday Machine
Matt Decker yeah not will Decker will
Decker was the motion picture thank you
then we took you know I was thinking
about Captain Ron Tracy in uh the Omega
Glory because you know it's sort of
close to July 4th and you know una
plebnista
um Captain Spock you know Spock was a
captain for about 12 seconds in Star
Trek 2. but he had no ego to bruise so
he went back to First officer
and then of course you know my my second
favorite Captain next to Captain Kirk
was Captain uh Cisco especially when it
became you know Captain badass Cisco
after he shaved the hair and had to
goatee
um but I realized I really want to lose
because Captain Kirk deserves the win so
I will go with Captain jelico
um from um chain of command as played by
the brilliant Ronnie Cox now Captain
Jellico was a pretty awesome Captain you
know everybody on the Enterprise was
sort of acting like it was a Holiday Inn
no offense but
he came and he made things Ship Shape he
put Troy in a uniform he got her out of
that stupid space cheerleader outfit he
he he he told Riker to get it together
stopped acting like such a wuss you know
go get your own ship he straightened out
the Enterprise D it would have been
great if he stayed on board and Patrick
Stewart could have gone back to doing
Shakespeare but Ronnie Cox you know came
for two episodes one of the most
memorable Star Trek captains one of the
best episodes I know everybody loves
inner light with the flute and
everything but chain of command is a
pretty damn good two-parter and uh
Ronnie Cox's Captain Jellico was
fantastic in both those episodes of
course he wasn't nearly as great as
Captain Kirk but you know what I had to
pick somebody
all right I I wanna this one's pretty
you guys gave some heated I have I I
have a leading here so I'm going to give
you one more chance to and it's really I
think you even called it yourself it's
really between uh Mark Dan and Brandon I
want to hear one more flop from you for
this crowd listen to the argument Kirk
versus Picard
go Dan
okay and you know listen I'm not gonna
sit here and say that Captain carpet's a
bad Captain because he wasn't it's just
the world that you're in and and the
next generation was great because it it
was more philosophical and it was much
more about treaties and negotiating
things and that's great those are good
skills to have but when I think of a
Starfleet captain when I think of the
the captain of the Enterprise I think of
that kind of swagger that Captain Kirk
had the tactics that Captain Kirk had he
had to think outside the box he had to
invent solutions to problems that didn't
even exist yet and he was the first
person to experience any of this stuff
so he didn't have that foreknowledge
Captain Archer was right right yeah well
Captain Archer would have uh that might
have been a good pick he could have
competed
but I but I will say that what I the
thing The Grateful thing about Starfleet
and starfleet's philosophy is going into
the unknown and that's why I think Kirk
has the edge is that he had to go into
the unknown uh on a on a on a daily
basis that's what the Enterprise was
there to do it wasn't so much managing
what we already knew it was the great
unknown of deep space and that's why can
I just say Captain Kirk was JFK and
Picard was George H.W bush there's no
comparison let me tell you something and
and the other thing is Captain Kirk is a
man who had the respect of his crew the
Loyalty of his friends and a green girl
on every planet he wins hands down
Captain all right and you get the last
word here to help they've been uh crap
it on your man there let's hear what
last thought
um
I can't argue with anything you're
saying
except to say that I I take issue I
think again I think Picard is
a more enduring character now granted he
had a lot more episodes
a lot more
uh and to say that Kirk was experiencing
things first
and Picard wasn't you yourself just made
the point that Picard went up against
the pork I mean Picard went up against
plenty of excruciatingly difficult
situations
I must I think I'm just a little more
cerebral and I I prefer a captain
like at like Picard could still be 80
and be a great Captain Kirk Man of
Action not so much the fact when he was
44 he was worried about mortality
all right guys it's up to you sorry you
even said to yourself you're out Mark
admitted I was gonna say Brandon made a
very compelling case for Picard that
said come on really all right don't tell
the poll results yet but I love that
Jack Shipley says on Twitter this Star
Trek movie fights has touched me and all
my happy nerdy places this is truly a
Sci-Fi Ned's dream so people are
absolutely loving this fight right now
I've had a round of applause for these
guys that was a good fight
all right let's light up the room
because I want to see how we're doing
this
white for Dan Black for Brett so white
for Kirk black for Picard what about
Jellico come on it's white yeah gets the
win
[Applause]
so that means Brandon has two points Dan
one point sorry Mark enjoy this special
episode we have one more round before we
go to a quick speed round let's cue one
more Montage from your cast of Star Trek
Beyond
I want to set this to uh uh if you're
stuck on an alien planet
which Star Trek bridge crew member would
you pick to be stranded with no captains
so we're asking the best crew member
who's the best player you want on a
desert island with you any show any
movie think about it while we watch this
clip cue the clip again
we've seen we've seen this on film who
would win in an actual fight Spock or
Kirk
ooh
spagger Kirk actual fight I mean I'm
gonna say me obviously but uh
all right assuming Zach's gonna say
Spock so Spock's got the
Sparks because you can do the Vulcan
pinch screen fight screen fight
feels incredible
what's at stake let's say it's over
control of who's gonna be the captain of
the Enterprise then I think Kirk would
win Kirk wins yeah if it's to control
the Enterprise what do you think is the
better Bromance you two Kirk and Spock
or Spock and Bones I right now it says
Spock and Bones probably unfortunately
all right karkin Spock Spock and bones
[Music]
yeah who'd make the better captain of
the Enterprise bones or Scotty
I'd go for Scotty I would say Scotty I
was almost positive you'd say both but
he knows his character well enough to
not be egotistical about it he's got
he's got a job that's more important
than anyone's and that's keeping us
alive who would make the better Starship
Captain Sulu or Uhura
you're mischievous
oh that's so Sinister on the one hand
Uhura can speak many languages and there
are people of various species on board
so you're gonna be unifier and the other
hand we wouldn't be able to get anywhere
if not for our Pilots this guy I like to
see Aurora be the captain I'd like to
see her take the help I think that would
be cool I think she actually would
probably be I mean no offense to Sulu I
love Sulu but I think I think ahura
actually would be able to listen to
Getting context before making the
decision I actually really liked that
idea Justin had an answer
what was Justin's answer he said Uhura
my Asian brother has let me down if you
guys are going out for a night on the
town you can pick any of the bridge crew
to be your wingman which one would you
pick I'm gonna say Simon yeah
you Spock that's a popular pick a lot of
people said Kirk which I can't disagree
because I didn't think Kirkwood Kirk or
yeah Kirk because the characters we're
talking about yeah oh character-wise oh
oh hypothetically who do you choose Kirk
Kirk really yeah well he gets the most
uh yeah what yeah he's gonna go to
credit yeah
he gets the most per position he's got
the most Swagger the most Charisma
um I mean basically you'd be you work
well off his runoff what I'm saying I I
take Scotty yeah oh Scotty would loosen
every situation up he sets it up nice
well he's an engineer yeah see I agree
with that because Kirk you don't want to
be your wingman he's gonna he's gonna
take away yeah exactly Spock I think it
might be a little too real well I'd take
Sulu
shooter
I'll just do it Sean Connery bashed
yeah how about a round of applause for
the cast of Star Trek Beyond
all right guys uh Mark you picked first
which crew member do you want to be on
an island with again no captains okay
well originally I was thinking savik but
then I realized when I was 10 years old
I had a mad crush on Kirsty alley and
it's really embarrassing so I figured it
can't be savic and and then I was
thinking Scotty in the Kelvin Universe
could beam people from One Planet to
like another solar system but I realized
that was only in the Kelvin Universe you
know that in real Star Trek you can't do
that so that wouldn't help me so I
decided I'd go with jazia Dax
and I'll tell you why you know what I
loved about Terry Farrell's performance
to Zia's ex she was really sarcastic she
was really smart
um she was you know she was friends with
everyone she had a multiple personality
disorder which probably has nothing to
do with the trill inside of her
um she was just a fantastic uh a
fantastic character and she hated
technobabble you know Terry Farrell used
to tell the writer stop writing me
technobabble I can't say it that was
another thing I loved about that
character uh I just thought that Dax was
a great character I think Deep Space
Nine was a great show and I feel it
needs a little love here today because
it's just not getting the love so uh
that would be my choice all right
Brandon who are you picking
well I would want to be stranded on a
desert island where somebody's smarter
than me
stronger than me
no emotional baggage someone who is
curious loyal ethical someone who could
live forever and loves cats data
[Applause]
that's all I have to say on the matter
all right we'll come back Dan who are
you picking uh well you know the
question is who you want to be stranded
on an isolated planet with uh my number
one priority when I think about who I
want to be stranded on an isolated
planet with is who can get me off the
isolated planet that I'm currently
stranded on I almost said Scotty but I
gotta go with the guy who I think has a
little bit of an edge I'm going Jordy
laforge and here's what I'm going to say
Jordi laforge number one he's the best
engineer in Starfleet and he has
technological knowledge Beyond Mr Scott
Mr Scott was an amazing amazing amazing
engineer uh but even in the episode
relics we see that Jordy has kind of
surpassed him he has knowledge beyond
what Mr Scott has that's not his fault
that's just that Jordy knows more
secondly jordy's got the visor or the
implants or whatever you know version
would he go with he's going to be able
to see more he's going to be able to see
more on that planet he's gonna be able
to see Pockets he's gonna be able to see
minerals something that can send a
signal something that can get you help
that's what I want I don't want to
resign myself to being stranded on this
planet forever
is it an ice planet or a desert Planet
alien planet that doesn't happen
you did say Bridge crew because jordy's
in in the engineering well but he's got
his station on the bridge he's got a
station on the bridge he's a bridge
officer I will fight you okay I know you
worked on that show but I will fight you
on that I don't remember I I
yeah he's welcome on the bridge anytime
all right quickly because I know yeah
you guys have some other commitments to
do we gotta get this too uh quickly
thoughts on why the others aren't right
we'll start with you Brandon
data can do everything Jordy can do and
more
and and and Dax is great She Blinded Me
With Science
uh data is not the chief engineer
jordy's the chief engineer he could see
more and I think that he has more one of
the great things about having a human
mind as opposed to data and you said
with that emotional baggage so I guess
we're going with the emotionless data is
that you have an intuition and Jordy
certainly had that he certainly got
himself out of many situations when the
Enterprise was gone he got himself off
of a lot of isolated planets before I'm
gonna go with the guy that I think could
get me off that planet as well Mark
well I think you know again you wouldn't
be specific about the planet whether it
was an ice planet or a sand Planet so it
makes it hard to really figure out who
would be most useful I mean we don't
know what planet you're going to land on
who do you want Oh you mean if I I know
I'm gonna crash you're going to crash on
a planet and isolated Planet you don't
know what it is do I have a shuttle
craft or am I stranded because the
transporter has malfunction there's a
lot of variables but which crew member
are you going to want with you well
apparently I said Dax
I sort of stuck with her I guess the
worst things I can imagine
um but uh yeah yeah but I I gotta say
you know data is always malfunctioning
and you know he got all these problems
he wants to be human he can't really
tell a joke well I I don't know you're
giving up again Sam for me for me it's
kind of like c3b on R2D2 if you want the
guy who's going to calculate the odds
that I'm gonna die that's data if you
want the guy that's C-3PO and data if
you want the guy that's going to figure
out how to get you out of the situation
that's Jordy that's R2D2 I'm calling it
and I gotta say well it's not just
because we're on time limit I thought
Dan crushed that and when Mark sided
with you it helped that makes it an even
game Dan and Brandon are going to a very
quick speed round how's that
wow that was a fight or I mentioned my
book
haha that was great fight before we get
to the speed round I just want to take a
moment to thank all our Plus members
because again we're able to do this
amazing thing if you want to join and
see nearly 20 original weekly shows
hours of live content join right now at
screenjunkies.com plus and you can use
the offer code SJ Central 16 you'll get
50 off the annual membership it's
amazing Deal TV fights is there guys
every week we got to get you guys back
on TV flights you would crush it all
right speed round we're gonna have three
quick speed around here the way this
work is you'll have uh 15 seconds to
answer quickly Brandon and Dan I'm going
to ask you a question you have to say
your answer quickly if you say the same
answer at the same time it's whoever
said it first uh gets it you'll have to
pick something else makes sense so we're
answering at the same time you and Dan
are going to be answering the same time
so as soon as I ask the question answer
quickly if you say the same thing we'll
hear who said it first and then you'll
have 15 seconds to argue and then 10
second rebuttals it's the answer yeah
buddy it's not like a quiz you have to
answer like out loud and be like oh I
think is there a buzzer uh no my
of all this TV series what's the best
Star Trek episode
uh all good things next Generation uh
yesterday's Enterprise also next
generation
15 seconds when you start talking go
ahead why is all good things better than
yesterday's Enterprise
because it's a it's it's a two-hour
episode it's more all-encompassing it
hits every character it's a character
Rich episode yesterday's Enterprise is
cool but all good things
it's one of the I think just a great
finale for that TV show
ding you'll have 10 more seconds Dan you
have 15 seconds go um all good things
was like a really amazing goodbye to to
an old friend I think that yesterday's
Enterprise was stands in the truck
because it's got like the Trinity it's
got time travel it's got alternate
universes you bring back Tasha Yar you
get to see what happened to the
Enterprise B which is or the invite you
can see which is like a big
10 seconds Brandon all good things had
time travel but it took place and
tashiar and it took place in three time
periods not two
uh
uh it was a more ambitious episode
uh we're not having a time period uh
competition here I just did the
yesterday's Enterprise is a better
sci-fi episode and a better Star Trek
episode all good things is a good
episode but it's sentimental it's not so
much pushing the boundaries of sci-fi
oh good all right lift those lights up
for me black for Dan White for Brandon
oh man oh yeah that's why
Brandon gets the first point okay I love
all good things by the way nobody asked
me but I would have said City and at you
forever
answer quickly ready
which piece of Star Trek Tech do you
most wish was real dick
Brandon he picked the Holodeck yeah I
would have picked the Holodeck
uh but uh I'm gonna I'm gonna go
fundamental
warp drive
all right Dan you're up first 15 seconds
uh the great thing about the Holodeck is
you're on a long space Voyage you need
something to entertain you and the
holiday can go anywhere you can go
anytime you go any place you can be
anybody it's the greatest recreational
tool ever made you don't it's not just
confined to space travel it can be on
your home planet it can be used for
anything you're right the Holodeck can't
take you anywhere
fake
warp drive takes you anywhere for real
and it was the single most important
invention of Star Trek transporter
awesome Holodeck 10 seconds down when
you start talking
again the warp drive is great for people
that want to be Space Explorers but not
everybody wants to be a space Explorer
the Holodeck is something that everyone
can enjoy it's something that anyone in
every civilization can enjoy it's not
just a tool for explorers it's a tool
for everyone last 10 seconds we're
running we're having a Star Trek debate
not your personal recreational uh and I
think that uh
warp drives more important
get out of your parents basement
all right uh White foreign
no I mean do you we need to do this oh
[Laughter]
yes you know
white for the Holodeck
for war
P Drive
oh sorry Dan yes that means Brandon wins
we're first ever Star Trek movie fights
that was an amazing on Earth did you
have fun
I had a blast thank you thank you so
much you guys I feel bad for the Silicon
Rock creature
all right uh guys I want to thank our
sponsor T-Mobile for bringing this to us
again uh double the LT coverage you can
follow the fights in more places so
please thanks T-Mobile thanks for doing
that I want to thank each of our
Fighters Dan Murrell you can see him all
the time but this was a dream come true
I got schooled by people that know
vastly more about Star Trek than I do so
yes that was fully expected absolutely
yes he did Round of Applause yeah for
each of these players uh Mark Altman uh
tell us where the 50-year mission where
can they find this amazing book of yours
it's on sale now it's 50 years of Star
Trek the first one's 25 years uh it's an
oral history of Star Trek Brandon is one
of the over 500 people we interviewed uh
it's the definitive history uncensored
the true story it's like being at the
coolest dinner party of all time Dan's
not there so it's even better
um and I'm kidding and uh I uh you know
it's on sale now booksters you know the
big buildings that have books in them
yeah and uh or online at any of your
favorite online retailers Brandon what
any plugs you'd like to offer anything
else you're working on to tell the
audience about oh yeah uh I have the
third season of my show Salem uh
premieres Halloween week
uh so please
please check it out awesome thank you
guys so much thank them so much Round of
Applause thank you too we'll see you
next week thank you so much bye-bye
[Music]
thanks again to sponsor T-Mobile with
double the LTE coverage get your screen
junkies fixed in more places to watch
our previous show click to the left and
to view everything else from screenshot